[Musik]
zündstoff für die groko die union und
die kanzlerin lassen die neue spd-spitze
abblitzen keine nachverhandlungen des
koalitionsvertrags
drastischer appel bei der
weltklimakonferenz wenn wir nicht
schnell unseren lebensstil ändern warnt
un-generalsekretär ish gefährden wir das
leben an sich und bauern protest im
kanzleramt die landwirte fordern ein
umsteuern in der agrarpolitik viele
betriebe stünden auf dem spiel
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten amt und ein
herzliches willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag an
meiner seite ist für den sport christina
hallo und programms bleibt die spd in
der bundesregierung das ist die große
frage nach dem überraschenden ergebnis
ihres mitgliederentscheids und vor ihrem
bundesparteitag auf dem am freitag
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
gewählt werden sollen das neue
führungsduo will neue bedingungen
stellen
doch eine neuverhandlung des
koalitionsvertrags lehnte heute auf die
bundeskanzlerin ab aus berlin las
bohnsack ruhe hat der
mitgliederentscheid bei der spd nicht
gebracht vor allem eine frage
beschäftigt die beteiligten wie geht es
weiter mit der groko wenn man den
koalitionsvertrag genau anschaut dann
sieht man ja sehr deutlich dass mit
aufgenommen ist bestandsaufnahme jahr
und auch zu prüfen ob auf kunden
veränderte rahmenbedingungen sich im
dinge auch verändert haben und mir neues
vereinbaren müssen während die einen das
thema also runter kochen wollen
plädieren andere in der spd für klare
kante gegenüber der union beharren auf
nachverhandlungen das schlimmste was uns
passieren könnte wäre dass wir in
verhandlungen oder gespräche nicht viel
oder gar nichts erreichen und bleiben
dann doch in der groko dann wäre
natürlich auch das neue führungsteam
komplett diskreditieren doch aus der
union kommt weiter ein klares nein die
cdu-chefin derweil im kosovo unterwegs
nimmt änderungen am koalitionsvertrag ab
wir sind keine therapie einrichtung für
die jeweiligen koalitions
regierungsparteien und deswegen gilt der
koalitionsvertrag
aus der opposition kommt die
aufforderung an union und spd schnell zu
entscheiden wie und ob es weitergeht
politik ist kein wünsch dir was sondern
wir haben eine gewählte bundesregierung
und diese gewählte bundesregierung muss
jetzt mit ihren drei koalitionspartnern
insbesondere der spd sagen ob sie dieses
land weiter regieren will
wir leben in das zeiten wo es eine
enorme polarisierung gibt in der
gesellschaft und in solchen zeiten nicht
kann man nicht so eine regierung als
dauer hänge partie im praktizieren
die designierten spd chefs bleiben dabei
sie wollen den koalitionsvertrag in
wichtigen punkten neu aushandeln
der parteitag am kommenden wochenende
soll darüber entscheiden
bis dahin dürfte in der spd noch hart
gerungen werden
der theo koll in berlin noch ist die
neue spd-führung nicht bestätigte soll
auch auf dem bundesparteitag geschehen
wie viel rückhalt haben die beiden in
der partei nun einerseits haben sie ja
die es für die interne wahl mit gut 53
prozent gewonnen
aber das heißt auch eine knappe hälfte
war gegen sie und dazu gehören sehr
viele im sogenannten partei
establishment also in der fraktion bei
ministern und beim ministerpräsidenten
diese alte parteispitze radikal zu
ignorieren dürfte den beiden nicht
gelingen gleichzeitig aber müssen sie
natürlich ihren anhängern etwas neues
liefern also das konzept weiter so ist
mit olaf scholz klar abgewählt worden
was passiert denn jetzt noch diese woche
vor dem bundesparteitag der spd
das wird zu einer art dreisprung im
advent morgen und am donnerstag treffen
sich die entscheidenden spd gremien und
erarbeiten den sogenannten leitantrag
also diesen inhaltlichen
forderungskatalog den mann dann der
union rechtzeitig zum nikolaus schicken
wird
endgültig entscheidet dann der parteitag
ab freitag darüber und das ergebnis wird
dann genau die hürde sein die man der
union hin stellen wird und dabei wird es
dann entscheidend sein wie hoch die
latte gelegt wird denn wenn am ende cdu
und csu nicht bereit sind über diesen
stock zu springen dann stolpert oder
stürzt die groko was im moment angeblich
keiner will einschätzung von theo koll
aus berlin hat sich im landtag in
thüringen haben sich linke spd und grüne
auf einem
der heiz regierung verständigt ziel sei
die wiederwahl von ministerpräsident
ramelow von den linken
die drei parteien wollen nun ausloten
wie man mit cdu und fdp zusammenarbeiten
könne
bei der landtagswahl war die rot rot
grüne mehrheit verloren gegangen
das letzte wort über die
minderheitsregierung sollen bei den
grünen und voraussichtlich auch bei der
spd parteitage haben die linke erwägt
eine mitgliederbefragung nach madrid
dort beginnt heute die 25 die
weltklimakonferenz zwölf tage
verhandlungsmarathon mit 180 beteiligten
ländern
dabei geht es vor allem um die frage wie
lässt sich der mensch gemachte
klimawandel aufhalten
bislang steigt der globale
treibhausgasausstoß ununterbrochen dabei
müsste er 2030 um 7,6 prozent jährlich
sinken um die erderwärmung auf 1,5 grad
zu begrenzen
aus madrid marko
verhandelt wird in madrid den vorsitz
hat chile
die 25 der klimakonferenz ist eröffnet
zum auftakt mahnende worte unsere
entscheidungen wir werden bestimmen ob
wir einen liegt der hoffnung oder ein
hartes aufgeben es ein schlag unter den
gästen die neue eu
kommissionspräsidenten sie macht
deutlich die eu soll vorreiter werden
von der leyen will dazu eine billion
euro investieren und schon im märz ein
klimagesetz vorlegen wenn es also unser
gemeinsames ziel ist den kontinent bis
2050 klimaneutral zu machen dann müssen
wir in der eu jetzt handeln wir müssen
unsere politik jetzt umsetzen
in madrid geht es um mehr ambitionen um
hilfen für arme länder und um eine lücke
die die letzte klimakonferenz in
kattowitz hinterlassen hat es geht um
regeln für artikel 6 der die
zusammenarbeit von ländern vorsieht
beispiel ein industrieland finanziert
ein projekt für erneuerbare energie in
einem entwicklungsland eigentlich gut
wenn jetzt aber beide länder die
treibhausgas reduktion in ihren
nationalen bilanzen verbuchen wird sie
doppelt gezählt es wird also geschummelt
robuste regeln sollen genau das
verhindern denn ein solcher mechanismus
ist wichtig gerade auch für
industrieländer
wenn die industrieländer klimaziele
haben wollen die mit 1,5 grad kompatibel
sind müssten sie bis 2030 35-40
treibhausgas neutral sein
das werden sie nicht voll erreichen
können ohne dass für einen gewissen
anteil davon auch dieser mechanismus zum
einsatz kommen kann
der erfolgsdruck ist groß denn schon ab
dem nächsten jahr soll der klimavertrag
von paris umgesetzt werden auf dem
gipfel geht es auch darum die zu
überzeugen die bislang kaum etwas für
den klimaschutz tun china und die usa
zum beispiel kein land stößt mehr co2
aus oder auch australien größter
kohleexporteur der welt daran will die
regierung auch festhalten obwohl sich
gerade in australien der klimawandel
immer drastischer zeigt normen odenthal
berichtet
wenn sidney dieser tage im rauch
verschwindet hat das einen grund die
brände die unweit lodern und warum
brennt es diesmal so verheerend ist das
nicht auch völlig klar klimawandel 1000
prozent nein ich bin alt genug
ich weiß es besser neumodischer quatsch
natürlich hängt das zusammen es wird
immer heißer das merkt doch jäger und
die wissenschaftler sagen es uns doch
klipp und klar das ist knapp an
unaufhaltsam gnadenlos nie gab es mehr
branded nie waren so viele außer
kontrolle
die feuer fressen sich durchs land und
dieses land ist leichte beute
geplagt von einer rekord dürre in
manchen regionen fiel seit jahren kein
tropfen regen wenn australien ein opfer
des klimawandels ist dann zugleich auch
ein antreiber kohle das ist das große
geschäft darauf setzt die regierung
australien ist der weltgrößte exporteur
eines dreckigen rohstoffs aber vor
risiken und nebenwirkungen verschließt
man die auch was wir exportieren wird
anderswo verbrannt dabei entstehen
riesige mengen treibhausgas in die
atmosphäre geht ohne zweifel trägt
australien mit seiner kohlepolitik also
ganz erheblich zum klimawandel bei die
feuer die durch das extreme wetter alles
scheint so naheliegend aber einsicht hat
es schwer down under umdenken erst recht
alles zum verhandlungs marathon auf der
klimakonferenz in madrid und weitere
interessante fakten zum klimaschutz
finden sie online in unserer heute at
oder auf heute.de nach hongkong
zuletzt hatten sich die usa mit
sanktionsdrohungen demonstrativ auf die
seite der demokratiebewegung gestellt
jetzt hält die regierung in peking
dagegen us-kriegsschiffe dürfen vorerst
nicht mehr hongkong anlaufen
außerdem drohen der new yorker
menschenrechtsorganisation human rights
watch strafmaßnahmen weil sie so die
begründung die gewalt in hongkong führe
während die stimmung zwischen den usa
und china angespannt bleibt rücken
russland und china näher zusammen
per video-konferenz eröffneten die
beiden staatschefs shipping und wladimir
putin das erste stück der insgesamt 3000
kilometer langen gaspipeline namens
kraft in sibirien künftig strömt
russisches gas aus der nähe des
baikalsees bis an die grenzen chinas und
ab 2023 weiter über die grenze bis nach
shanghai nach deutschland
meist passiert es zu hause aber auch in
der kirche in internaten vereinen auf
campingplätzen erwachsene missbrauchen
kinder und jugendliche mädchen sind
deutlich häufiger opfer als jungen
und gerade im netz hat die sexuelle
gewalt deutlich zugenommen
sie stoppen oder wenigstens bekämpfen
das will der nationale rat der heute in
berlin erstmals zusammenkam
britta spiekermann lichte rüttelte auf
wurde zu einem schlagwort für
unvorstellbaren kindesmissbrauch auf
einem campingplatz wohnen über zehn
jahre lang kinder missbraucht immer
wieder gab es hinweise
doch behörden versagten inzwischen sind
drei täter verurteilt das entsetzen
bleibt wie beim jüngsten fall in
bergisch gladbach von hier aus nur ein
bundesweites netzwerk aufgedeckt
massenhaft kinderpornografisches
material aufnahmen vom missbrauch der
eigenen kinder die dimension noch nicht
absehbar
süchte bergisch gladbach das sei nur die
spitze des eisberges sagt der
unabhängige beauftragte für fragen des
sexuellen missbrauchs viele mädchen und
jungen die sexuelle gewalt erleiden
werden übersehen und bekommen nicht
schnell genug die dringend notwendige
hilfe und deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass wir in der bundesrepublik eine
aufklärungs und
sensibilisierungskampagne in der
dimension der anti aids kampagne
möglichst bald starten heute trat der
rat gegen sexuelle gewalt an kindern und
jugendlichen zum ersten mal in großer
runde zusammen von kirchenvertretern
über kinder und jugend
hilfsorganisationen bis hin zu ärzten
und juristen
das ist ein unerträglicher zustand
dass wir so viele kinder in deutschland
haben die fans und auch jugendliche die
von sexueller gewalt betroffen sind und
dann müssen wir einfach zusehen wie wir
gemeinsam diese lage verbessern und da
auch nicht wegschauen sondern ganz
gezielt dahinter sind um aufzuklären um
zu helfen um zu schützen und um
tatsächlich auch täter zur verantwortung
zu ziehen
die praktiker lehrer und erzieher
fordern ganz konkrete hilfen zunächst
mal brauchen schulen fortbildung eine
qualifizierung damit sie mit dem thema
sich überhaupt auseinander setzen und wo
kolleginnen kollegen oft angst haben
dass sie etwas falsch machen
das wichtigste sei zu hören kinder und
jugendliche ernst zu nehmen im fall
löste gab es viele hinweise
doch niemand wollte sie hören und so
konnte der missbrauch jahre lang
weitergehen
der bundesweite bauern protest ist bei
der bundeskanzlerin angekommen
vergangene woche protestierten die
landwirte noch vor dem kanzleramt heute
schildern 40 gruppierungen angela merkel
persönlich was sie so wütend macht die
dünne beschränkungen zum schutz des
grundwassers etwa oder die geplante
verschärfung beim insekten und
umweltschutz
die neuen regeln würden die existenz
vieler betriebe bedrohen heike slansky
landwirt florian petschel versteht die
welt nicht mehr
nach den vorstellungen der
bundesregierung sollen seine schweine
künftig mehr platz haben
ein umbau sei nicht nur teuer sondern
führe auch zu einkommensverlusten so wie
ihm geht es zigtausend bauern in
deutschland sie sind sauer und laufen
sturm gegen das agrar paket deshalb lud
die kanzlerin heute höchstpersönlich zum
krisengipfel ins kanzleramt ein
wir haben hohe auflagen für sie zum teil
auf der anderen seite haben wir ein
dramatisches problem bei der
artenvielfalt ich sage ausdrücklich dass
wir nicht der meinung sind sie sind die
einzigen verursacher strengerer
umweltschutz und dünne beschränkungen zu
hohe nitratwerte im grundwasser dass
bienen schutzprogramm regierung und
landwirte mit unterschiedlichen
vorstellungen beim aktionsplan
insektenschutz gehen wir davon aus dass
wir das thema dies neu diskutieren dass
wir auf kooperativen naturschutz setzen
eine verfahrene situation tausende
landwirte machten sich vergangenen
dienstag erst auf dem weg in die
hauptstadt zu lange wurden unbequeme
entscheidungen auf die lange bank
geschoben produzent und konsument sind
so weit auseinander wie wahrscheinlich
schon lange nicht mehr in einigen teilen
in unserem land und wir merken dass es
immer mehr anforderungen gibt ein
landwirtschaft mehr tier und
umweltschutz jetzt sollen kompromisse in
dialog gefunden werden
im süden frankreichs sind bei schweren
unwettern und überschwemmungen sechs
menschen ums leben gekommen
besonders betroffen weil die côte d'azur
drei menschen starben in den
wassermassen
und in der nähe von marseille stürzte
bei einem rettungseinsatz ein
hubschrauber ab die drei insassen
mitarbeiter des zivilschutzes wurden tot
aufgefunden
und wir sind jetzt beim sport kündigen
ich habe zwei schöne erfolgsgeschichten
riesenlob in spanien für deutschlands
fußball national torhüter marc andre ter
stegen die schlagzeilen reichen von
gigant bis zur lebensversicherung für
barca nach seinem tollen paraden
sieg des fc barcelona bei atletico
madrid herausragend und außergewöhnlich
kollegen und medien feiern barcelonas
marc andré ter stegen bei atlético
madrid beweist der deutsche sein team
mehrfach vor dem rückstand 20 minuten
fußabwehr gegen airbus so dann kurz vor
der pause riesenreflex geben murata ter
stegen im tor der katalanen ohne fehler
kollege luis suárez claude seine
leistung war spektakulär den besten
torhüter der welt zu haben ist immer ein
plus und einen der besten stürmer gleich
noch dazu ist auch kein - leo messi der
argentinier 86 minute doppelpass mit
suarez inside stoß mit links der fc
barcelona verdrängte das punktgleiche
real madrid von der tabellenspitze dank
marc andré ter stegen und lionel messi
herausragend auch der deutsche eishockey
star leon dreiseitel in der
nordamerikanischen profiliga nfl der
nationalspieler erinnert mit seinen
beeindruckenden leistungen bei den
edmonton oilers immer mehr an den großen
wayne gretzky mit seinem treffer zum 3 2
sieg setzt leon dreiseitel seine
überragende saison in der besten
eishockey-liga der welt fort dreiseitel
steam die edmonton oilers wollen sich
gegen vancouver unbedingt für die 5 zu 2
niederlage tags zuvor revanchieren und
gehen durch john archibald in führung
aber vancouver kommt zurück
das libor markiert das 2 2 1 spiel
gedreht
doch dann schlägt die stunde des leon
dreiseitel in überzahl erzielte er das 2
2 und dabei bleibt es nicht
im letzten drittel gelingt ihm ein
weiteres tor zum 3 2 sieg mit 18
saisontreffern und 32 vorlagen ist
dreiseitel der zweitbeste scorer der
liga und mit seinem team auf dem besten
weg in die playoffs klingt doch richtig
gut
und zum schluss noch die frohe botschaft
es weihnachtet sehr zumindest schon mal
im weißen haus dass jetzt diese bilder
veröffentlicht hat first lady melania
trump legt letzte hand an damit die fest
dekoration im us regierungssitz so
richtig zur geltung kommt vom kunst
schnitt bis zu rosen borte am kamin
all das sei
zitat bilan ja eine wunderschöne
demonstration von patriotismus das
wetter noch im norden bleibt es meist
trüb im süden wird es zeitweise sonnig
die einzelheiten hat gleich gunther
tiersch christian sievers freut sich auf
sie im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
hier ist morgen petra gerster dran und
wir verabschieden uns wünschen ihnen
noch einen fröhlichen montagabend machen
sie es gut
[Musik]
konami liebe zuschauer einen hauch von
winter gab es heute morgen in den
mittelgebirgen wie ihr hund zurück in
rheinland pfalz auch an den alpen es hat
ja ein bisschen geschneit jetzt gibt es
wieder viel ruhe beim wetter ein
hochdruckgebiet breitet sich aus von
westen legte sich über mitteleuropa sind
anfangs noch dichtere wolken dabei die
heute nacht und morgen noch über den
nordosten ziehen werden im süden scheint
die sonne heute nacht auch noch so ein
paar schauer thema weiter über die
mittelgebirge richtung süden ziehen mit
schneeregen mit schnee und zusammen mit
dem nebel überfriert das ganz oder kann
es eben sehr glatt werden verbreitet
wird es nämlich frostig also meist so
zwischen minus 1 und minus vier grad
minus sieben grad über den schnee
flächen an den alpen im nordwesten
bleibt es frostfrei und morgen haben wir
norddeutschland ja dann eigentlich ja
das mildeste wetter mit 8 grad sonst
nach südosten sind es null bis plus 2
grad
es wird in norddeutschland ein trüber
tag werden teilweise regnet auch ein
bisschen uns weht ein kräftiger west bis
südwestwind in süddeutschland haben wir
mehr sonnenschein im norden nur mal
vorübergehend ganz kurz aber richtung
schwarzwald vor allen dingen richtung
allgäu erscheint dann die sonne vor
allen dingen wieder auf den bergen aber
auch in der donau schaut die sonne mal
kurz vorbei ja die aussichten es wird
sonnig sein bis zum freitag und auch
freundlich mit ein paar wolkenfeldern in
norddeutschland aber dann fängt es am
freitag im nordwesten an zu regnen und
es wird sehr wenig ich wünschen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie es
gut